入ったけどてるねはいありがとう
j
ねあのーなんとか母も知覧のバリア
バリアーどいくぜヒャッホーですおっ今日はできないよと
ではお金が倉庫でございます
た
ええええええ
はいも近くまで来たんですけどもあの持ち株すごいですはい
目だけよ
これまでなくな座でちょと思うはずだ
[音楽]
ba 分じゃあまずのトゥイッチのこれパっ子様を癒せる
予約ジャズ踊っての
月電話から来たそこれえっ
あ
んちょみんなポケモンゴーやってんじゃんほらみんなスマホ触ってるよ
うわぁ時代だなあもうすぐ着きますかね
ああありがとうございますそうこれから人すごいねー
平山みんな腰てる the すげーなやっぱみんなみんな僕ももうする
どんどん no fun no 大泉する
の声ません
待って同じた同じさん
goo
終わりますよえっ
どんだけじゃなくだったんでちょっとちょっとちょっとハイ枚数そうなんかめっちゃ
周りの人が落ちてるみたいです皆
いやそっちも聞くれたもんだよ床はドーンが終わっていいのかなぜここだよ
横目に来ちょっと現像花でていただきますとなんかたワンピースがスーツしすぎてて
gp せが浮かなくなっています
なんでなんで選んでるん
際路傍
wh
26がんばれ
さあああっ1回ちょっとはついきましょうこう頑張って下さいはいあります
me
パーク内はダメなんですけど周りはいける御立
入れない人はいああああ
どうするこれをもってもってインターネットに繋がらないよ
なんでー
何が起きてるんだちょっと離れてもらってぐるっと一周して多分電波が今集中して言っ
て繋がらないんでぐるっと一周してもう1回いきます
で本当にもう待ってこの家じゃないですよええ
ヨーロッパのお金かかっちゃうぞれ設計
ヨーロッパの両方を浮かせようとしたので大自分はテザリングすればいいんじゃ
秋田却下あテザリングさってある種や貯蓄もできないマンあれだわパパ a
テザリングオプションで別契約がああなるほどねえこれでた瞬間にはじめ507
じゃあもうはず弁護されてもいいやもういい俺もバリアー土壇 no つかめること
だけに長は私は願ってるん
よし
気づきましたーーー
もうたらどうするこの後またいってさあ同じようなことになると強いよね
とりあえずも落とさないようにしていこうレタスとたら戻れないから受けちょっと
パークの近く入ってみます
じゃあ掴まれなかった俺今日マジなやつや水害私なら他に捕まえられるんですよ
俺は
パリアードをあきらめかけます
もう時間がない
俺はそう思って最終兵器を使った
そう
2人の一でしょ2人乗り自転車に乗っていればアルギス魔法せず
ある旧で速いペースで卵の部下の距離を稼げる
そう
を言わせ夏
[音楽]
勝ち組な赤レンガのポケット部付近で取れる2 k 卵からはレアなポケモン生まれる
ヒャッハーめっちゃめっちゃめっちゃバレルベンツ生まれるか皆バリアーず頑張ってね
これだろロイヤルとしたのだが残念ながら
自転車に乗っている間はバリアー度に出会いなどです
ちょっやっぱだはいというわけで赤レンガ倉庫付近に行ってきたんですけどもバリアー
ど
スカ前でもスターハァハァうーんとりあえずバリアーが本当ヨーロッパですけ出ないん
で本当に皆さん捕まえでる方は捕まえておいたほうがいいです
ヨーロッパの良否が浮きますからねでちょっと今から行く人にちょっと注意事項なん
ですけどもう本当にネット環境が悪いですいつはポケモンパーク内は撮影禁止なので
掴める瞬間だけスクショしてきました
まずこれに
キロ卵もう会えれもうほらあのポリゴンが出たんですけどももう多すぎてバグで
ポリゴンが表示されないっていう
とりあえずも何もかもが重かったこの会場はもうひょっとしたらアプリが起動できるか
どうかのレベルだと思いますポケット4もあっても反応がありません
重すぎてねほらみてもうこれさ見えるもうバリアーがいるんですよ
いや反応もいるんですねこれアンのアンのアンボーン
バリアーでもいいって僕頑張ってこれをソートしてるんですけどもタッチが全く賛同し
ませんバリヤードはずっとポケットペタペタ触ってるだけっていうこの状況が約5分
続きましたをエラーが出ました
めっちゃめっちゃタッチしてるのわかりますバリヤード結果的に粘りに粘ってタッチ
まくったらようやくバリアー土に触れて無事線とつかみ易いまで入れたんですけども
本当にきついですよ僕がどこもんだったからかもしれないんですけど本当に回線が
ひどくて行くね
ヨーロッパ限定のポケモンが日本で捕まえることができましたで安藤の無事何とか
捕まえることができましたのねいつは今回はこの赤リンガー
お目当ての子源は無事ゲットすることができました本当に回線がすげー混んでるんで
get by ファイトが持って行ったほうがいいのかなとりあえず僕は普通にその子
だけ持ってきとめちゃくちゃ辛い思いをしたというお話でございますバリアとを
つかめる時は皆さんお気をつけて
じゃなく
me
あああああっ